[Music]
absolute
ah what a lad well what I should say is
what a couple of lads as today I'm
joined but not one Crusader all black
Legend but two of them now both of these
Lads have had 50 games for the Crusaders
and over 20 caps for the All Blacks but
unfortunately for the next eight months
those tallies will not be increasing as
they've both had major knee surgery they
will put them out for the year and
including the Rugby World Cup but I am
stoked to have them Honestly by
seriously good lads always full of
energy they are of course the lads
themselves George Bell and civil Reese
welcome ladies thanks for having us on
the uh this famous party here Jimmy mate
you guys look good you sound good sound
crisp on the ears
and it's like a dream come true
my man just waiting for the caller yeah
here we are here we are finally got you
on and both of you together I'm looking
forward to having yeah like I said not
just one but two Champion leads on
foreign
but how is that like you guys obviously
um you've both had pretty serious knee
injuries however knees feeling like
you're still in the brace Geo but Siva
you're out you're ready to go yeah
um yeah obviously
um did my ACL and
um wasn't until I went to go um get the
surgery done and they found out that I
had um she damaged
um the bone
so yeah there was
um yeah pretty gutted because I couldn't
put weight on it and you know it delays
the process a little bit yeah yeah
um yeah I mean George and a bit
different and obviously you can see he's
an Embrace and I'll give that to him
what have you done George yeah so the
pretty much uh ACL gone uh MCL and the
PCL so it's here multi ligament um it's
quite unfortunate and there's kind of a
freak accident the way it happened and
um yeah but the reason why I have to
wear the braces the PCL to protect the
PCL because it still takes a bit longer
for it to kind of heal up properly
um
but yeah that's kind of my my knee
happened what two weeks after Series so
um yeah saw him down and then I decided
okay
I'll come and join you brother and uh
we'll do the journey together just like
we've done the journey together
because you two love together too all
right yes yeah no uh civil's uh been a
good uh he's my landlord at the moment
so yeah
um he's uh been kind enough to open up a
room for me and um yeah so I'm staying
with him and his beautiful family which
is which is good and um yeah he's got a
nice beautiful daughter as well and
um yeah Me growing up in a in a family
with a lot of kids it's it's good having
little kids around to to interact with
and play with and watch them grow as
well so yeah yeah yeah oh cool and so
you've just done your
and had some bone damage and you've done
all three of them but the rehab's still
the same nine months for both of you
yes yeah yeah it's a bit of um yeah
because we've done different things it's
I think the first about first three
months our rehab is it looks a bit
different yeah but then I think they see
it around week 12 to 14 will start to
kind of come together and it'll look
quite identical the way we start
rehabbing so yeah it's the first couple
months where we're totally different and
then we'll start to join our tracks
together and then um should be running
in in kind of directional movement
together as well and when that time
comes you'll be into it until yeah yeah
so yeah around nine nine months for
sieves in I think myself they reckon
nine to twelve oh yeah I'll make it nine
but you mentioned it was a bit of a
freak accident so what what did actually
happen uh yeah we were
um more defense uh and uh
um I guess it was a what is it um yeah
pretty much a
a more that just wasn't going anywhere
so the the Reds um I think the rigs
hooker
um tour of the more and then um he got
tackled
and try to spin out of the tackle back
into the mall where you know we were in
really dark places and
um yeah I had no idea it was coming so I
couldn't do anything to protect myself
and he just came in from the side and
um or I just felt it like I could just
feel it like oh I'm sure the boys didn't
hear me but I I did scream so it was uh
I just was like straight away everything
was going through my head like oh man
this is me I think I think I'm done for
the year like yeah yeah so you knew this
straight away yeah and um it did feel
like a dislocation and straight away I
kind of like it felt like oh this might
be a a dangerous one man so
um yeah I guess yeah walking back to the
changing master I was expecting the
worst so that I guess when the news did
hit me or you know didn't hit me as hard
which was um which is I guess a good
thing but
yeah it was yeah it was the worst uh
yeah but that's how uh my one happened
what about you seven years was in the
Blues game hey man this is the moment
I've been waiting for what happened
um yeah I still remember it was just the
start of the second half and I try to go
over the wall which
a good mate of mine um decided to
yeah stopped me from hopefully going to
the World Cup now I was uh yeah Rico
came for oh clean out and
um yeah he was uh you know just one of
those cleanouts where they sort of you
on the side and oh yeah yeah but yeah it
was just uh Unlucky One you know he was
like sort of sitting on my knee and
twisting me at the same time
yes it was similar to um you know as
soon as it happened I just felt my neck
going and I was like I try to get up and
run again yeah man yeah yeah got up and
I just couldn't even run I was like man
I never I had anything like that that's
why I knew straight away that's probably
the
because you haven't had many injuries
either eh like you're you're built to
get through everything
I have been yeah I've been lucky um like
you know this is my first major uh
injury so
hopefully the last resort was it an
illegal clean out type setup or just one
of those unlucky ones I had the video on
my phone like it I didn't have the phone
um
it was just one of those unlucky
cleanouts like you know
um you know I just yeah I was you know
it was my setup you know like I was
standing over the wall and when he went
to go because he was sort of sitting on
my knee and when he went to go test me
and
I couldn't even do anything because I
sort of had my knee locked in there and
I just couldn't do anything so it's
nasty yeah like yeah even think about
how quantifiers knee injury that
incident of similar to that yeah like
well you're in that position and those
clean outs are the ones that are doing
guys knees with some pretty serious
damage a somehow we need to clean up the
game in that area where those we can get
away with like not so many of these
neanderies uh yeah true Manda
I'll be interesting to see what they do
about those um cleanouts because
you should have a punishment for the
person that if she does a clean out in a
maybe and I was thinking about it here
we go we're going off topic again
it talks about it every day but imagine
you know if say someone puts you out for
eight months you're out yeah that
whoever did that injury to you or like
they have to do the same wow yeah it's
like a stand down period once it's ready
to go and then you that would be allowed
that would be brutal way people would
have no plans
we've already got 16 injuries if we take
anything
oh crazy so when you obviously when you
find out that you are out for nine
months
how does that news hurt yeah obviously
massive year for both of you Rugby World
Cup year how did you handle it when you
when you were told the news
um oh yeah because obviously won't
happen first
um you know when like when it first
happened you know I was just thinking
you know the best
um possible outcome I was like no this
is just you know like a MCL
and I was like it's just something
little Linden hit all the scans and you
know they yeah you know doc told me that
or you've done you know ACL and there's
going to be you know I try to denied for
man I still remember for about over a
week I was like an adult like we can
like do something and yeah that sounds
crazy about it and I was I don't know
you know they're always sucking the
whole treatment yeah um you know that
they actually did go through my mind as
well trip to Fiji get these leaves and I
was a man in a World Cup year uh Super
Rugby is just pretty much just getting
started and
um yeah but it was it was so gutted man
um and then yeah and obviously not long
after that you know happened to our mate
haters also but in a way you know I mean
now it's you know I've sort of passed it
and having Geo um obviously we're living
together yeah she knows makes the
journey a bit more sweeter than yeah
what it would have been if I did it by
myself
was the same for you Geo yeah it was um
yeah once I kind of
did find out the official news from the
surgeon
um yeah kind of went in a bit different
my mindset was expecting the worst like
I'm expecting that I'm out so
um yeah so like you know when when he
did tell me I wasn't as like oh down
about it
um but yeah I kind of just had uh yeah I
did think about you know um I guess
opportunist to represent you know
possible opportunity to represent our
country at a World Cup you know one of
the biggest
um sporting occasions in the world kind
of thing so and it only comes around
every four years and um yeah all those
things that go through my mind but
um I'm quite lucky not lucky but I am
quite like a religious you know quite a
religious and it's quite like a strong
in my faith and believe that everything
happens for a reason and uh I believe
that my God kind of puts everything
there for a purpose and so that was kind
of also a bit of um help me with my
mindset and to try and stay positive and
understand that this is here for a
reason and maybe it's all part of it for
to learn something about myself and my
journey and
um yeah maybe find other things outside
of rugby that will help myself and my
family and my friends so that's a kind
of Outlook I've had on it and um yeah
it's it started off well for me and I'm
enjoying the rehab at the moment and um
still still do like to look outside and
watch the boys train and you know they
still have the urge of like man I wish I
was there or yeah but um yeah then I
kind of just refocus and understand that
you know it's all part of the journey
it's all part of yeah part of it so yeah
yeah but it's such a good mindset such a
cool mindset to take into any injury I
think but you mentioned a few things
that yeah want to do grow yourself or do
outside of rugby anything you want to
share what uh well yeah we um I was
actually talking to seven other day that
we might um actually start like learning
how to really really get good in the
kitchen and a bit of knife skills and
baking and stuff like that because we've
got a lot of time we realize we uh after
rehab and gym in the morning we've got
the whole other off so it'll be good for
us to kind of I guess uh yeah expand our
knowledge
[Laughter]
but we've also actually
um uh signed up for you know some some
coaching courses and stuff so we've uh
we've actually got our level one now
coaching certificate wow
and uh we'll probably get into our level
too but uh I guess it's something there
that we're we're just um yeah kind of
just to stimulate our minds while we're
in this kind of stage of of rugby and is
that something you could see yourself
both doing post footing he is probably
under eight so yeah
um I haven't really thought about uh
thought about it yet post footy um in
terms of coaching but yeah um I guess
he'll we'll be have something or good to
have like that eh
um and we both interact well with people
and um and kids as well so
um yeah
um but yeah we've got what got out on
the ball as well and uh
um but yeah I was also thinking like
because I've got a lot of time as well
for myself it'd be good to kind of maybe
pick up on
um my studies which I left which I left
way behind um uh yeah it just also to to
get the Mind mind and the Brain kind of
ticking or else I'll just be a gym
junkie and
um but yeah uh so what study did you do
uh I was I was doing a bit of teaching
yeah and then um yeah I had my final
year but then I was I got kind of
correct I moved up yeah and moved up in
the in the Rugby World and they've got
one year to do to get a teaching degree
is that right uh yes yeah okay yeah and
it's I think it's still validators been
about five years now but I I checked it
I think last week and it's still valid I
was like oh yeah
all right so yeah yeah but um yeah we'll
see we'll see and there's one more
project that I've seen you're sort of
doing around around the base whether we
camera Etc but yeah you're holding it
pretty tight um what are you gonna what
are you guys doing there what
what's in the bag there what are you
doing there
um oh yeah that's right this is the
master planer right here he's like the
Peter Jackson over there yeah
um you know of course when we both
obviously and I think we're going to be
out for the season and you know it was
you know every day would talk about or
come up with ideas of new things to to
try and do or like fill in time and yeah
and then um Geo actually mentioned that
it'll be cool for us to um capture like
the just the journey
um of getting back to you know when we
do return to play
um and it's yeah a pretty cool thing you
know because that like you know we every
day we're just you know taking photos
and videos of all the our rehab stuff
and you know it's just being real and
everything we do so um that way the uh
um and obviously the planners
um you know to put all of this together
at the end and um you know and show the
fans or the people that follow us and
it'll be a good um inside we're good for
the fans or just the people out there to
see what it actually takes
um to get back to playing in in the
process as well which is really tough
yeah yeah it's cool I love that and who
are you gonna just release it on your
sales and Netflix approaching yeah or uh
I've been in contact with Netflix so um
and neon as well
waiting for them to to reply to my
emails but um no we'll probably just uh
release a few videos here and there on
YouTube or
um we're just thinking of a name so you
know if you've got any good names Jimmy
or maybe we could get it to the audience
what have you got sofa any good ones or
any ideas yeah no we actually yeah we've
thought up some silly ones but uh not
suitable yeah um but yeah we're just
trying to think of a name and um and I'm
just trying to get my head around video
editing and yeah and things like that
and we'll just try to make it as real
and raw as possible yeah um but also
like just to cover on the the whole idea
of it was also just uh
um for also people in the same same boat
that are not in professional
environments um man I've seen like you
know the general public and
if they if they get ACL injury man like
the amount of work it takes for them to
get it back to normal is huge like for
us to be in every day it's like a lot of
work so
um just little video videos out there
for I guess Club players that have had
the injury just to help them
um you know see okay I can do this and
do that to
I guess um you give them a bit of
knowledge on on how to help them through
their injury I mean it doesn't also only
have to be the knees it can be whatever
um because Siri always shares his
mindset
um and rehab and stuff so he take a few
gems from that um who is watching the
video so but yeah it's just to kind of
help the
um people out there in the same
situation or people who just need a bit
of motivation that are going through
similar injuries and stuff um yeah so
cool have you released any yet no no
when's the first release like when when
are we thinking when can we expect one
or is it this is the jack Grant yeah
hopefully let's say hopefully by the end
of May and early June yeah we can yeah
just probably like a snake Pig Yeah Yeah
and um yeah we'll kind of run up I guess
right now maybe weekly or maybe
fortnightly kind of videos off right of
our journey up until
um of us take the field which would be
pretty cool
um yeah and uh graduate I guess right
through the injury process yeah and you
guys you'd probably be taking the field
at the same time roughly too eh yeah
yeah if we do all the rehab stuff right
if we nail it and is it Crusaders 2024
round one yeah
geez yeah 2024 yeah
um
be it the new stadium is sold out two
boys returning if we hype it up properly
oh go good
and is that something you can see
yourself doing even post injury like a
bit more content or content creation
it'll be yeah pretty pretty cool I mean
that's the way the world's moving you
know like the movie movie obviously you
got your podcast like this and it's
reaching out to
learn those little skills while we can
and um yeah just have it in our back
pocket for when our time does come in
handy we can always you know check it
out there and use our skills then so
um yeah I'll definitely be um trying to
learn the most I can about the at all
how the hell this technology Works in
video editing and things like that so
um but it's quite funny Once you kind of
get one video another Video Edit
together and it's like whoa this is
actually yeah cool and you can actually
be real creative and use your your
creative juices it spreads pretty yeah
it's actually quite addictive I can see
you're excited about it yes
oh that's good stuff but one thing I do
want to talk to you guys about obviously
you both got really awesome Journeys the
way you've sort of come through civil
from Fiji and Geo from second 15 or
um your school but
um I do want to go through those
Journeys we'll start with you Siri
um growing up in Fiji and what was it
like for you growing up in Fiji
obviously I've been over there a couple
of times now and you always just see the
kids just playing Just footy all the
time eh like in the water or on any
field they can get on it's just it's
next level over there
um yeah yeah like you said you know
that's all I knew and that was just
obviously that was the life that I knew
um
and I grew up in Fiji I was born there
um it wasn't until
um I was 15.
yeah when I moved over to New Zealand
and that's all when I
um you know moved over here and then you
know to see a way different life if we
live here you know it's I mean that's
you know you just have all these moments
the flashback moments he's just you know
just so grateful and
um I love the life that I you know that
I managed to live in Fiji and what my
parents taught me and just everything
um you know things that I could carry
with me for forever and
yeah it was pretty you know special
um you know growing up in Islands
you know so then moving over here trying
to
um trying to get a life and um yeah you
know make the most of every opportunity
that comes my way and um you know I
didn't even think
any of this would be possible or be
sitting here
um but yeah so
um
so what what actually bought brought you
over to um New Zealand came to Hamilton
boys yeah yeah so
um when I was 15
um
he was 15. I was playing first 15 in
Fiji oh yeah yeah and
um yeah I was playing for 15 for my
school in Fiji and
um when my team we made it to the to the
to the finals that year and like they do
every year they have all these schools
that come over to Fiji to um you know go
to scholarships to because that they
think and I go all go to the rugby yeah
stuff like that so yeah I was
um I still remember
um I was approached by this Australian
school and
um yeah no just like any other kid in
Fiji man it's
um you know any opportunity it comes
your way you don't really think twice
about it you just almost just yeah I'm
taking this one because you know
anything to to get out of Fiji
um you know just to for a better life
and
yeah and then so their Australian school
came to me and and I was all set to go
to Australia and
um and wasn't there well because that
was the semi-final week that the
Australian school approached me and the
week after and that's when Hamilton boys
approached again
and yeah they approached me and I told
them oh sorry I didn't have already said
yes to the school here in Australia and
so it was all set that I was going to
move to Australia and
um because I didn't and then because
Hamilton boys I didn't know that you
know Henry Spade all those boys they
went to this yeah and so what Hamilton
boys did they got hold of Henry's fade
and a few other Fijian boys to message
me to tell me that do you go to Hamilton
boys yeah and you know when I saw their
messages and stuff like that and you
know being a Fijian you look because I
remember hearing respect all this was
you know you look up to them enough and
yeah I was like oh man that'll be cool
and I was telling my old man oh no let's
just change it on I go here now yeah and
yeah you know we changed it and at the
end of that year moved to New Zealand uh
went straight to the boarding house and
it went straight to school there so it's
crazy so almost and Aussie mate could
have been playing for the wallaby yeah
sliding doors hey that's crazy and what
position were you in BJ because like
you've got all the skills okay King kick
off
um yeah same video I was playing
I was playing second five in fullback
all right yeah so I was playing second
part in full week and kicking girls yeah
and kicking goals too excuse yeah
um yeah
moved over to New Zealand even for the
first four the first 15 here in Hamilton
I was playing the similar positions I
was playing 12 and 15. oh yeah yeah so I
didn't play Wing at all and this is a
fun fact I've never played booing my
whole life until
I made my first um debut for waikato oh
really yeah just like any other Fijian
right yeah you're locked or anything
you'll end up on the wing I'm telling
you this there you go Geo you'll end up
you'll end up on the wing right whether
you like it or not just
no it's opposite for me
it was opposite bro
oh and how did you find going to
Hamilton boys obviously I've spoken to
Noah about it on his episode like how
professional and how full-on that rugby
program is coming from Fiji in an eye
opener man yeah I was just like because
I went to boarding school in Fiji as
well so in the boarding school here like
in Hamilton like you know it's just just
comparing the two of them was a man this
is like a hotel like a complete to what
I was what I just lived and
um but yeah it was man the the training
their program there is it's just crazy
um you know that's why they the best in
the world you know I know because they
won that World
um first 15 or whatever it's called and
yeah and because Noah's old man actually
you know close to your case yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's a funny story like when
we used to train first 15
um would be you know you'd fall on into
training and oh it would just be on the
sidelines you're still a little honestly
I see if but now I'm always telling you
you were still in nappies
you're still in Memphis who were the
first 15 training but yeah it was crazy
because he was actually on the sidelines
would be like that like the ball boy
would be you know giving us or running
in water to as well and stuff like that
yeah yeah
um but yeah training you know they train
like Monday mornings and
um they almost trained like three times
a day and that's almost they trade more
than I rugby
and they and then for their preseason
games they would play like Prim teams
like Club teams yeah yeah honestly they
just I don't know what the what Noah's
old man's thinking like yeah let's put
all these kids to play all these all
these dads and all these older guys and
but yeah it's you know that's just how
they do it and it's been working for a
very long time and yeah yeah it's yeah
it's pretty cool and it's official too
yeah completely different to your school
age yeah well completely different uh
hurry up man maybe one training a week
for our first 15
[Laughter]
um
[Music]
but so you grew up in Wellington am I
born in New Zealand yeah yeah born and
raised in the lower Hutt Wellington yeah
um I mean uh yeah winter
um did all my schooling there in the Hut
um up until my dear title College yes
that's right yeah so first all black
ever from that yeah yeah I thought there
was one way before but no they must have
just got a photo of someone
yeah so yeah apparently I am the first
uh all black from third college and um
that's pretty pretty special I guess so
yeah especially from um a neighborhood
that's you know quite a low
socioeconomic area and um yeah it's
always good going back and um going to
my club and uh showing you know the next
gen that it is possible yeah from from
you know you just have to put in the
hard work so yeah and savory obviously a
very gifted rugby player gifted athlete
scouted at a very young age I think you
were quite different weren't you yeah I
went exactly um the one everyone was
trying to get in their first 15 where
yeah Matt I was uh was the Wonder
uh going the water bottles on yeah
you know
oh man
yeah definitely a bit of a late bloomer
uh well I didn't do it you know I didn't
do a single gym at school in a high
school uh I didn't stretch them until
but I think I was 20 or
um so yeah I was just grateful just you
know just loved loved rugby they still
loved rugby and watching and playing
when I when I got minutes so
um but yeah yeah it wasn't the yeah kind
of came up the I guess the long way
around and yeah slowly grafted away and
grind away and eventually kind of got he
got there so um so you weren't in the
first 15 at all yeah literally the water
yes there were times where I was like oh
yeah we might need you on the bin shot
okay yeah gear up uh no yeah
um yeah I was yeah I I was first 15 for
a bit but but um yeah I remember playing
15 as well and
um because I wasn't needed here for 15
but I guess at the time then I was in a
a probably
back the coach as well because I
probably wasn't a great rugby player you
know just overweight I was unfit to
understand rugby at also yeah
um but yeah yeah so so how did it all
turn around for you how do you go from
um that position to I guess one of the
great All Blacks yeah I would um I
started
um I guess after high school I started
kind of hitting the gym and I'm taking
rugby a bit more more serious and
started to get a bit more fitter
and uh I was playing a lot of sevens
like Club sevens because clubs haven't
seen and Wellington's huge so
um it was a good way to to get myself
fit and get my skills up to par and
things like that so
um and I started to kind of um yeah my I
guess rugby style kind of to change and
um I started to enjoy it a lot more
because there was a lot more further I
was a lot more skillful and
um and yes kind of transferred from a
prop through to uh I guess I was playing
seven and eight for like uh for Avalon
prims back then so yeah it was a it was
um yeah a transition from that front
road to loose season oh man I love
playing Lucy zones a lot more freedom no
scrams it was like yeah but um yeah and
that's kind of how I kind of started
um getting into more yeah serious rugby
and uh yeah I was fortunate enough that
after the high school to get straight
into I'll make um Wellington under 20s I
think yeah so there's a Lucy as a as a
prop oh I was playing prim's Lucy yeah I
don't know how that happened but uh I
was jamming prop so
um but yeah it was just that I think the
last two years off uh the two years
after high school was just that little
change of mindset and fitness and gym
and and uh kind of changed my the way I
play the rugby like rapidly and just
yeah all of a sudden change and yeah I
guess the it's when the rugby genetics
started kicking in and stuff I realized
oh yeah I can actually play I can't
actually play with it no
um yeah so that's cool sevens you don't
often see props especially like unfit
props you go and put themselves out on
the seven sphere because that's like the
worst place you want to be if you're a
unfit Pro like you said not that much
skill but yeah and once you sort of
Unleashed at putting yourself in that
yeah that sort of environment mate
you've flourished it yeah it was
actually
um our I guess a village team from where
I'm from in Fiji they formed up in
Wellington and so
um because I'm from there I'm like yeah
I'm going to represent my end that's how
I kind of started playing a bit of
sevens and
um yeah we've been up to Thailand
receivers which is a huge kind of Fijian
sevens to comp in Auckland and
um yeah and I guess growing up as
fijians boy like yeah sevens is the
number one sport you watch because
you're so good at it and yeah and we
love the way they play they're just so
fluid and so and so you want to go and
do that as well because your fijians
yeah and that's what else it kind of
inspired me to play with the sevens as
well yes it's in our blood as fijians
and yeah so I love it though love the
seven so then you end up getting picked
up by otago how did that happen yeah so
enough so I was playing Club rugby at
Wellington and then um
um
my uncle works on the interislander and
so he's um he's he's
an engineer on the inter island end so
he's talking to electrician on on the
entirely there and his name was Marty
Paris and Marty's like yeah we're
looking for a few Fijian boys tomboys
salmon boys if you know anyone to come
and play for a club in Dunedin and then
my uncle's oh yeah I think I caught my
my least my nephew back at home so he
comes back to me and he's like oh these
guys in Dunedin you know send them to
your rugby CV and they'll pay for your
flights down and um and so yeah with
accommodation and and you can go play
club for them for a season I was like oh
yeah but um at the time
um
uh I guess my fiance now was living down
there who went together so I was like oh
she's down there as well so she always
she uh she she believes she's the reason
we'll just say it was Harbor Hawks but
uh so yeah ended up sending it through
and then um Harbor Hawks kind of
um shut me down and uh yeah ended up
moving down to Dunedin and um yeah began
a new life there and it was so new new
to me I mean seeing the student life and
you know like living up in Wellington
have no idea what's down south until he
moved down there and it's like oh this
is actually a big University Town
there's so many young people here it's
actually a nice like little scene to be
part of when you're you know 19 20 21
um but yeah so Harbor Hawk shut me down
in um played Club rugby before Harbor
Hawks
um sponsored by Chipmunks
but yeah I'm sure Spades will know a lot
about how books as well so
um and uh yeah in the ended up playing I
think 80 odd uh premium games for them
so yeah yes
they'll be like no you should do
something but I see it must be yeah so
yeah so how many seasons did you do
before otago came knocking um yeah so I
moved down that uh 2014. so that's why
there's almost a decade ago and then um
and then that year there were shortage
and props so a managed to get one cap in
that 2014 the year I moved down I was in
there for a couple months and I played
for
otago and there was yeah Tay Wilder and
they had uh Lee Allen yeah leelan yeah
um they had uh yeah a few of the aquise
a few of the old older dogs that I I
call them the old Italian boys but you
know because they're all gone now but uh
they were playing overseas but uh and so
yeah played play that one and um was
kind of in the mixer up until yeah
didn't get a cap until 2018 I think so
44 years yeah four years where I didn't
get any um had the debut going no good
uh yeah
we lost against Northland I think that's
when uh Dan Pryor covered up against us
here after so
um but yeah that was yeah debuting I
just remember how fast the game was I
was like first professional game also
this is fast man yeah I couldn't believe
how fast the game was I was I was I was
only I think boy
109 110 dripping weight I was yeah well
I was still holding the scrum but just
staying there so
otago I think that summer they gave me a
whole lot of mass protein to go away but
shift some turn boy came back the next
year
can't make the Nexia 125.
125 so I ran a PB bunker that year
before
um that 2014 came back 125 I think I
like I was one of the slowest props I
think I ran like a real like a 15 yo-yo
oh wow it's like that's real low age
we're like was that you breathing he was
like nah
I was like it was probably one of the
strongest I've ever been but it's just
so unfit like I didn't get that balance
right it was no Goodings there was no
they just told me yeah come back you
don't know dude I'm like I'm listening
to you all right I'm gonna go back up
don't do any Fitness like I did no
running at all I had no idea I was like
what is this man now thinking back to
I'm like [__] that a silly man that is
silly yeah so it sort of took you four
years to find that balance to become the
right weight right Fitness and
understand the gain that you were yeah
trying to play right yeah I guess it
yeah four years uh I kind of yeah gets a
bit more mature and uh they realize that
you know you have to have that Fitness
in your game you can't just be big and
strong and
um once again I took on sevens again and
I started training with their Taco
sevens if you uh you you probably
wouldn't believe it and uh actually went
to go Jam a tournament for otago b7s and
uh yeah you know I found it was a good
way to get me fit again skills back up
so
um yeah over the four years I was just
finding that balance and and getting the
yeah the balance right between the the
size and the fitness and and the skills
and things like that and um fortunate
enough when I was you know I didn't get
injured or anything
um being a different size it was quite
um lucky that I didn't get injured
um and my body was able to withstand
that weight but I managed to trim it
right back down and kind of put in 2018
and yeah kind of played for otago again
um and so that was pretty cool yeah
called up here by uh Tom Donnelly and
been hearing and um yeah they gave me
opportunity uh and then yeah I took it
with both hands and um I think there was
this one game and
um uh it was against Canterbury and I
think I played like 76 77 minutes of the
whole game like I'll call into a Target
or we need here boys have gone down I
hadn't been training with them until
winning boy played like
seems and still felt fit 76 seconds yeah
I was like man the sevens you know that
lower kind of energy Reserve is there so
um and then lucky enough that was the
the game that Jace Ryan was watching and
so he kind of based um his selection for
pre-season off that game and
um yeah so he he came into Crusaders
after that through um through Jess Ryan
and the main reason why he's picked me
was because he saw how how long I was
working for the I guess the engine that
I had yeah the right man to impress him
yeah yeah and that my old man always
told me like you just never know who's
watching every game ever opportunity to
get just take with two hands because you
never know so yeah that's pretty pretty
cool but um yes that's the kind of the
long journey that I had up into
professional rugby yeah what about you
sever you were a bit different are you
sort of just broke straight onto the
scene and NPC scoring tries fan all over
the show no Fitness issue
um yeah or that you know I've I finally
get in school
very very lucky
um you know I got signed on my my last
year in school when I was in year 13 and
yeah and then the end of the year
you did pre-season and stuff and I was
kind of similar to George and I started
playing sevenths in
um yeah actually started playing seven
tonight she started to take seven like
pretty seriously because I was like man
like I would love to actually Place
events like internationally and
and yeah but I didn't see I had to kind
of stop because you know I was playing
miter 10 and and I was it was my first
year so you know I was just it had to be
like
you know I've had my best footballer
every time so
um yeah played miter 10
um 2016 and it was my first year yeah
played
yeah
how many years is that yeah and um yeah
you know similar to Jill you know I mean
they named the Suburban team was the end
of 2018
um you know oh yeah because every year
when I was playing miter 10 you know you
sort of you know set different goals
every year and then
and a big dream of mine was to place the
burgundy and I don't know this sounds
crazy but you know because I came
straight from Fiji to
um to Hamilton and Chiefs was the only
team that I knew in and I was just you
know I'd love to play for the Chiefs and
yeah there was the only team that I
wanted to play for
um yeah and I stayed there
um you know I'd go in and train with
them
um you know when they
um Avengers or need numbers and you know
just yeah but I was just doing that for
like things are for like four years I
was just doing that and nothing really
happened ah true was it that long yeah
yeah and um you know and you know talks
would you know they'd like tell me all
these things and
um oh yeah this is this you need to grow
this this and it wasn't until
um the end of uh maybe 2018 when they
named the you know they named the super
ugly teams and yeah I was sitting I was
just I remember I woke up that morning
and you know all the teams had been
released and I was like no phone calls
no nothing and then I was just a man of
dude I'm not disgusted because you know
I felt that I've you know been playing
some good rugby and and then again I was
that morning I was just laying there
just seeing the Super Rugby team and
legit I just got up to have breakfast
and
my phone went off and was like ringing
and I've seen this number and I was just
like man I don't know whose number was
this so I just let it ring and I was
like okay no never mind and then rang
again
and then but when it rain again I wasn't
I wasn't by my phone so and then but he
left the voicemail and then I picked it
up and the voicemail was uh Hey series
uh that's Scott Robertson yeah yeah and
I thought it was just someone taking the
bus you know because probably someone
might make to knew how bad you know I
wanted to play Super Adventure yeah yeah
and I picked the phone up and I rang it
back and and it was Razer and you know
it was just like oh hey mate um you know
we've got um the All Blacks that's you
know like the All Blacks and how they
come they don't do the preseason and
yeah it says oh I've got a few all black
boys um it'd be great if
um you know if if you want to come down
and um and then join us for preseason
and straight away and I told them well
mate I would literally do anything right
now I would you know I'd leave today if
I'd like to come down to Christchurch
and
and then yeah and then he told me oh my
our manager will get in touch with you
and that was good old flitch
um the assorted flights everything and
it was that the turning point for anyone
watching yeah I guess that's we have
let's meet as well yeah I still remember
that was came down to uh on the
screening thing that they do you know
where you just with the physios and all
these testings and stuff yeah that was
the first time I actually met Jill and
um I actually was I was talking to him
and it wasn't until later
um but then I asked him I was like oh
what position do you play because I
thought he was actually a Lucy yeah
that's crazy the whole time I thought he
was a Lucy that yeah that was good times
man and yeah you know from
um when they all happened in I mean with
Israel dag
um because he announced his retirement
um the start of 2019 and
um yes in you know because I was covered
for him that's
um yeah and then you know they told me a
few months after they uh oh we'll keep
you down here
um because there's all the eggs just
announces retirement so but yeah I was
so happy yeah it was good but like I
mean yeah it was a Davis man as a top
man and watching him you know as I was
growing up it's just a crazy athlete
yeah what was the feedback you were
getting that was stopping you from
getting an opportunity earlier like um
seems a long time four years yeah yeah
it's yeah I mean probably yeah someone I
call ball on some of that
some of those coaches
um I was I was like oh because you look
at me like I'm not the the tallest
um
um you know and they said to me
basically that you know they've got this
list of players and I'm literally right
at the bottom you know they had
um you know James Lowe all these other
boards like Tony Pulu
um
this um yeah I feel like all these other
other guys there like what I mean
they've pretty much it to me oh you know
you've got all these guys and uh we just
think they're better than you you know I
still remember
um I don't know I should say his name
yeah
um
assuming about the conversation that was
with uh straws yeah yeah good old
strawberry yeah you know just told me
that
um you know I had all these guys in
front of me and I wasn't good enough to
play Super yeah
um yeah you know I remember I was
meeting him and in the room and I was
like he was telling me that I don't even
know how to take it I was like oh well
um and then wasn't until we played the
Chiefs that my first game was for it was
when we played the Chiefs
yeah and um and it was the best feeling
and I still remember that week when
Razer told me oh you're gonna be
starting this week and it was against
the Chiefs and I was like man this is
the game I wanted to play and then you
know that game there was was it was a
cool game and played all right and so
the game was on I don't know Friday or
Saturday and then by Sunday the Chiefs
pretty much had a contract again for me
yeah sure yeah yeah so the game was on
Friday or Saturday and then on that
Sunday the chase you wanted to sign me
because they knew that I was
um oh yeah yeah yeah yeah so those
cheeky going man straight away they're
like oh I've got a contact here for you
you know you want to sign it like you
are ready yeah
yeah yeah
but yeah there was um you know that's
pretty much the journey here that's
crazy yeah and then your journey to the
All Blacks happened pretty quick yeah
see that yeah I mean I put down there it
was like that's oh yeah I don't even
know how it happened yeah it's freaky
and then
uh he was 2019 let alone my first game
for the full Super Rugby in here
um in that year to 2019 just always when
I've just got selected into the All
Blacks and as a World Cup year to as
well and like things were like happening
so fast for me and I was like man like
yeah the whole just almost watching
things unfold and I'm like man this is
it's crazy and yeah and I mean like you
know I was I was pretty lucky to
surround that you know I had guys like
um like Richie and Davey you know those
guys you know if I'm being honest here
those guys could make people look good
yeah like as much as but those guys
um just what what they do man like you
know Dave you mean he's a wizard like
things he can do and even Richie like
most of my tries I scored that yeah it
was was off Richie's kids
most of it was off Rich's cross kicks
and got to a point and I was like man
this is good I'm scoring twice maybe I
just keep doing this yeah it happened so
fast and you know I managed to be the
years you know consistent every week and
um you know all this all blacks um talk
and stuff it was honestly I didn't even
think about it at all and
um yeah they named the first um for the
rugby championship and then the first
Squad and it was live on TV and because
George and I we lived together too on
our first years yeah
we're both laying down
um
yeah we're just laying down there
watching the TV uh just laying there all
the guy was just like naming the and
then yeah
it was scary
it was Karen Reed was informal here in
the name yeah called my name out and man
that was
it's like like a dream yeah boy this guy
just sunk into the couch like that and I
wouldn't start hugging you yes
[Laughter]
and then his phone just started going
off boy what a it was awesome to
experience that moment yeah
and how did you when did you get name
not this time no my my one was uh when
was it 20 I think 2020
um
um says uh Tom Donnelly called me into
his room and I was like George I want to
talk to you this morning we're about to
kick off a meeting and he was like
talking about them my game in the
weekend I was like oh yeah yeah yeah and
then um he got a call and Shandy from
the All Blacks and then he gave the
phone to me and he knew it was coming he
just told me to get into gave the phone
to me and he's like oh yeah this is
Shandy um we're calling say that you've
uh been selected to travel to Australia
to 2020
um Australia squad or something like
that and man I was just before I head
down and I was like ah
I was kind of like yeah tears tears and
then CS was like We'll go
um tell the team and so went into the
team room for otago and yeah cess told
the team and everyone started cheering
and that's when I was like I can't hold
these teams man this is an awesome
moment it's such a special moment man so
yeah
um yeah I found out with with my otago
boys and um yeah straight after that
called the parents and you know um the
the misses and yeah yeah so that's so
cool yeah and then what was it like for
you going into the environment did you
feel comfortable yeah it was definitely
intimidating yeah my first roommate was
uh Sam Kane you know we got to Australia
um and then I got there but uh
fortunately enough you know it was the
first night
um yeah because uh you know I'm not a
snorer but I snore
it's uh the first night I've knocked out
knocked out and I was you know just
trying to go to sleep straight away
in the north of Sun and I just yeah roll
over or like I just hear pillows like
it was my story
and we're quite deep sleepers as well so
we cancel each other out so
unfortunately enough of my experience of
uh Sammy Kane I was like at the time you
know being new to the All Blacks
environment it's quite scary but like in
my snoring yeah it got me out
a room with it now but like you know
like far out semi Kane you know yeah
[__] yeah
then and then your first game mate like
what was what was that experience like
oh yes that was um at Mount smart so
that was 2021 was a nice game yeah Tonga
was it yeah
where I came off the bench in um yeah
yeah remember singing the National
Anthem and you know Say More Story the
tears come rolling down your eyes and
you think of you know the sacrifice and
the journey that you've been through
while you're singing The Anthem and you
just sing it with so much pride and
passion and because it comes from the
heart man it's it's a special feeling
and it's
yeah you don't feel it much like doing
anything else
um yeah it's it's a different feeling
um and then yeah running out against
Tonga and
um yeah I guess getting my kind of taste
of International Rugby was definitely a
special moment in the whole family were
there to celebrate and watch me receive
my kept so
um yeah and uh yeah when did you feel
like you were good enough to be in the
All Blacks did you did you feel like it
from the start or do you still feel like
it or like yeah oh I don't know I think
kind of just
uh
just uh I don't know yeah definitely no
at the start I definitely didn't feel
like I was yeah I guess good enough to
to be a part of the team but um
um I always get told you I'm selected
there for a Reason by my family and
friends and um I always put my best foot
forward and so I kind of had to try and
yeah change my mindset to
um I actually deserve to be here
actually I'm here for a reason and I
need to put my best foot forward and
really push for her you know for a place
in the 23 kind of thing and so um that
was probably yeah after that my debut
after the Fiji games I think there was
that year then my mindset started to
change and I was like oh yeah I really
need to be the number one prop kind of
thing and just have that mindset so you
can actually push harder not just be a
float around and say I'm happy to be
here yeah yeah you know I'm all happy to
be here yeah all black now and now you
can't have that in the in that
environment or else you get figured out
quite quickly and someone younger and
stronger can come up easily and take
that spot so yeah yeah so what about you
Civ are you similar or are you pretty
confident all the way through no
honestly enough because yeah like that
yeah right at the start like I said
another 2019
you know guys like
um you know he'd like Reggie
um you know Rico uh Ed Ben Smith yeah
um was stuck in the hall yeah it was
always in
um yeah that's all just so focused and
like just trying to play consistently
and super ugly and when the All Blacks
happened I know it's almost I had to
adapt
faster to as well quicker if I want to
be I'm seeing that because like what
George said you know you get recognized
for a reason and
you obviously have to almost play up to
that standard you know and show them why
you know they obviously they chose you
for a reason so you have to show them
why you know you belong there and
um and then you just have to start
growing a game like very fast in and in
here like in every like every year now
there's always this like new guys that's
coming through all you see guys carving
up but super ugly level of this just you
know gives you the I guess
oh man and what but it's a good thing
it's a healthy thing to have and yeah it
keeps you in your toes and makes you
work hard every day if you want to be
you know the um the national level and
and up until now it's yeah that's nice
watching all this especially now even
now banging out injured yeah yeah just
watching like the Supreme people man
this coach has probably forgotten us
[Laughter]
so your first in your first year was it
you said Rugby World Cup yeah so those
massive games I remember going to that
first one uh South Africa and we're
seeing you out there and doing like wow
this is like such a cool must be such a
cool experience for you yeah the idea
like you know I mean
no Japan
sorry yeah you weren't in the 2011
[Laughter]
um yeah now that that yeah the World Cup
man because
like you know let's work up as the
Pinnacle yeah of rugby and that's
like I was the afternoon we know when
they named the team
um and the All Blacks you know training
when they named the team you know for
the World Cup and I was like like in a
way I was like man like being like being
selected to go to the World Cup it's
like
I don't know what can beat that you know
and then being able to play yeah that's
even more special when you're just
standing out there running out and you
see the stadium packed and so we made it
right up to the semi-finals and yeah
even before they see me finals I was
like man like
this is top four if we do well here you
know who knows you could be part of a
winning
um lift up the World Cup uh but yeah it
was just like I can't even find the
words yeah to describe yeah it's so cool
and then talk to me about sort of last
year obviously you didn't get as many
opportunities last year
um what do you sort of put that down to
what are your thoughts around that
um yeah like like
um in the All Blacks environment when
you don't get selected like you you know
they set you down and you catch up with
the coaches and they give you um
feedback
um yeah they give you feedback and stuff
like that which allows you to go and
work on her when you do have work on
times and
so yeah you um you need to have those
feedbacks and you just keep doing it and
um yeah it was frustrating for me
because you know I was because like last
year I've you know I felt you know I
felt good I was like you know consistent
and
um but in the near you go into that
environment and obviously it's up to the
coaches you know the type of game play
they want to play and all these things
and like you said earlier and it's a few
times I've been told that you're not
going to play this game because this is
going to be a high ball game and like
you I'm sitting there I'm like and like
I don't get me wrong I can still get up
yeah but yes just because I'm sure it
doesn't mean I can't yeah I've been told
like is she a few times there I'm not
gonna get played because this game here
you know this team's gonna kick us out
all highball and I'm like and that's sad
yeah
sorry yes
um yeah and you know last year and
you had all these guys do as well like
you know I said Wingers in New Zealand
like that's a tough pretty tough
position to resolvement like you know
they have got
um yeah like Caleb Clark is in their
um mumbles into it as well
yeah Lester this is all those guys it's
yeah competitions always just real tough
um
and what about you Geo last year for you
how was it
going it before you got injured how are
you feeling yeah I was feeling feeling
good
um uh yeah it was it was definitely a
lot more um I guess last year do a lot
more I felt uh the props the front row
was a lot more competition
um in terms of
starting and trying to get into that 23
um especially the lucids it was uh gruda
myself and offer so we're kind of going
at it which is it was good it was
healthy competition and that's what you
want because that's the only way you can
grow if there's no competition then hell
can you get better kind of thing so
um yeah and uh yeah managed to get a few
games and rest a few games as well so
um uh but yeah I found it found it still
still an awesome opportunity to you know
be a part of the All Blacks last year
and travel to the northern tour and as
well as South Africa and
um still be a part of it and kind of in
the mixer so uh for me it was also kind
of learned a lot about my my game and
scrumming at that level against some
some big boys as well and kind of
getting my head around it and um yeah
taking a bit with me that I can kind of
I guess feed on now to to know you know
what it takes kind of thing so
um but yeah I did enjoy last year and
um got some good game time for the for
the All Blacks as well which is uh
fortunate and uh yeah yeah how good so
what are the plans going forward for you
guys once you once you're recovered and
you both sign with the Crusaders for
two more years
um until next year next year yeah in the
next year and you're the same or you
yeah longer uh hasn't been released yet
but oh yeah
25 till 25 so yeah yeah when's that
going to be released this episode
[Laughter]
yeah and is that with New Zealand Rugby
as well
um yeah yeah fortunate enough yes yeah
so how good another two years in New
Zealand and I guess I kind of made my
decision around um good good just kind
of settle down here and I think you
start start a life with my partner here
as well you know you never know I might
have a kid or two yeah is that a little
family here before
I get older and wiser and uh speak
speaking of kids you've got a another
one on the way pretty soon yeah yeah
um yeah well literally anytime now so
anytime now here we go yeah keep the
phone on yeah no that's yeah exciting
and like I said with with this injury
yeah um because when I
um had my first daughter
um I remember I was at the berth in had
to pack my bags and leave the day after
oh yeah
that was tough because I you know missed
I think so like the first
eight weeks eight weeks wow yeah
yeah that was it was tough in like now
um you know this engine like sort of the
timings of everything
um kinds of Falls like perfectly because
now I could be there
um to help my partner in
yeah and just be there for the first
those important crucial times yeah do
you know what you're having another girl
another girl yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
an exciting time so your your sign with
the Crusaders and New Zealand Rugby
Union for one more year yeah one more
year well yeah one more year because I
mean with the because we know the whole
plan was to
um you know this year obviously World
Cup here try and you know play a good
rugby and go to another world cup and
you know I guess things
um probably could have looked different
if and if I wasn't injured yeah um
be in now because a man just sort of you
know puts me up for you know one whole
year with the Sawyer so you know now I'm
sort of you know having to rethink again
um you know what my plans are going to
be so maybe stick around New Zealand for
a bit longer yeah who knows yeah so
you're only 26 is that right yeah and
you're 30 yeah 30 yes yeah it's still so
young both of you yeah yeah
exactly a young full price another 10
years for me
do you reckon you'll be able to play
till 40. yeah do you yeah there we go I
reckon I can I'm a quitter could have
you know didn't play professional Rugby
teams so I'm Still Still fresh here no
you're only four years then yeah
[Music]
well that's gonna be good stuff what
about you a bit harder for a Winger to
still be going when you're 40 unless
well this is
yeah we're talking about it
whatever no is it but is it still
playing now
I think he's like 58 now yeah
all right
thank you
have any of you got Ambitions to play
overseas at all at any point or don't
know just see sort of yeah look you
obviously probably did up until the
injuries yeah yeah
I was like yeah I was in I had plans off
um you know I would want to just go and
experience what life is and what rugby
is overseas and
um you know like I said like he's
mentioned earlier I mean I'm still young
I could always come back to New Zealand
um be I'd 100 would love to go overseas
and see what it's all about yeah yeah
same here yeah I guess um yeah being pro
rugby players you can use it to travel
the world now as well so um definitely
after I'm done New Zealand maybe look
over to Europe or
um you know the American competition by
then could be you know doing really well
or potentially Japan so it's yeah I'll
use it to to go and travel the world and
see other sides and I guess experience
other cultures as well so yeah your
content game would be unreal in America
[Music]
anyone's looking for a content creator
um
give me a shout out oh but that does
segue beautifully into these um these
questions actually because one of the
first ones is around the drawer team
would you ever play for Fiji Andrew
um man
um but no I don't hear if I'm being
honest I mean I would love to yeah I'd
love to play for the draw but
um I just I mean I don't think or
financially is it no I mean oh I don't
even know I mean if they get paid well
or but yeah I mean that I'd probably if
I had to go play for them draw would
probably be later in my career yeah just
to finish because obviously we played
them over there this year you're a God
over there everyone loves you there's a
Chevy trucks all over the town right but
it must have been a pretty cool
experience to play it over yeah against
them no I was cool because that was the
first time my period my um family has
watched me played oh really before I
left
um
before I left
um Fiji yeah yeah all right yeah so it
was cool you know but yeah their
question um play for the drawer probably
be late in my yeah my Rugby career or
yeah yeah I'd definitely love to play
football yeah it'll be an awesome
experience playing for you know a a
country team kind of like yeah Fiji for
Fiji kind of thing so for draw based on
Fiji
you love the nature
but my kids love it over there too they
always want to go to Fiji that's where
they ask to go whenever I say do you
want to go somewhere they say Fiji
it's a beautiful place that's a
beautiful country but it's so cool that
they're doing so well as well and
they're like seeing them beat sides
and they're probably gonna make it yeah
the rest of the drawers so
well they're definitely a different team
at home yeah
you obviously out there both you're out
there too yes you're both out there that
day what was it like for a front rower
in the heat sweetie ball fire out I was
I think I I like um I rolled my ankle
earlier in the game oh because the
fields are a little bit larger like
that's how long the grass you couldn't
even see your boots when like your boots
were like covered like it's like boy the
capital the divots I ran into a divot
when I was going to carrying my ankle
roll like this I was like nah so the
rest of the game I wasn't there like I
was battling my scrummy I could only
scrum on one leg and I was just waiting
for like the coaches to pull me it was
yeah he was like doing that
it was like a single league
but it was my my main kind of block
shoulder too so it was like all right
I'm in one here man
um but yeah it's definitely a different
you know different environment to play
in the field the heat the crowd all
those little factors you know yeah they
they do have an impact on the The
Players mentally as well for the thing
especially if you're used to playing at
the top of the line Fields yeah the
lights the weather's always perfect I
don't think it's different that's why
it's so different going over there
because it's just environments that
we're not used to but then we're all
love it yeah
yeah it's cool it's cool to have an
experience like that in Super Rugby okay
next question who was your favorite
player growing up
hmm
my one was why solicit Ruby oh I was
watching Stevens I just tell you know
the magician man the magician just how
graceful he was eh just made everything
look so easy and like how he could just
fool people just on the field it was
very similar to you on the sevens field
I always thought I would look like him
but now what's the playback that
definitely is
[Music]
man that's all we you know growing up
there you just so growing up in Fiji
you'd um you know yeah you don't know
any other players yeah you just watch
57th or the 15s so yeah just watch
sevens a lot and um you know like
William Ryder oh yeah the footwork of
that man that yeah like you know him I
remember just watching him and every
time we'd go out on the field playing in
my mate yeah just pretend to be here be
him and um yeah and funny because when
I'm and then when I moved to New Zealand
um and then sort of and I started to
watch something more of the All Blacks
and the Crusaders and actually it was
what I'm hoping I mean this guy knows a
dessert but he he gives me so much about
it as well
um
yeah he's always my favorite oh was it
and yeah so he I still remember he did
this interview with me when
um when he was with Sky Sports this in
at the end of the year he did this
interview with me because I know the
stalking they do you know they go
through all your social media and then
he found like in my on my Facebook like
right down it was like 2004 like 2011 or
15. I changed my profile photo to him
and then he told me that was like in
this massive interview he told me to
tell him the story he was just still
telling and telling the story not to
tell him the story about it so you know
Israel dank was um
yeah the Goosey the the guy oh jeez
right that's crazy and then you end up
replacing it and then I end up replacing
him yes it is crazy and it's a little
bit like what in your story or how you
pick up the Super Rugby trophy as a
teacher and then you're getting a photo
of you holding it a couple of years
later yeah talk me through that one no
that was yeah yeah so I was I was a
teacher read and then we were um that's
when the Highlanders won the Super Rugby
trophy in 2015. so we all got visited at
schools and then uh yeah managed to you
know pick up the church I think we're
allowed to but I didn't get fined or
anything but I did say I did get fun
anyways I was got a photo with it
and then um
yeah I guess we fast forward a couple
years later four years later
um managed to play in a grand final with
the Crusaders at home here against
hogwartis and we left the trophy again
and yeah I'm holding it in the in the
changing rooms and like man this is
actually you know you've done it yeah
you've done it kind of thing and like
yeah
um that was my debut year for Super
Rugby as well as this fella so yeah for
us to both be a part of the finals
um and you know lift the Super Rugby
trophy it was oh you you just think
about like how things happen like that
man like man that's crazy yeah the game
the game of rugby and how it all lines
and how everything pans out yeah
it is crazy but so cool it's why I love
talking to people about it but who was
the last who was the last player you
want to see chasing you after an
intercept
who do you hate who would you not like
you obviously get a few intercepts who
do you not want to see trying to chase
you down
or it doesn't matter you're gone
no one's kids from behind man
um I said it'll be um
yes
in my opinion you know he's the fastest
rugby player in New Zealand yeah
um like in New Zealand in like I
wouldn't be surprised if
you know in Australia to as well like
just yeah he's that guy's quick man he's
he's fast and he'd be the last guy I had
one you know yeah after making an
intercept you're feeling good about
yourself you're like yeah and then you
look back seeing him chase you and what
about the first guy you'd want to see
[Laughter]
go on a knee brace
[Music]
yeah well for me would be it would be
freaks man yeah it'd definitely catch me
like real easy you know because he's
he's so fast and I still remember the
um the All Blacks game
um that we played in in Perth when Tom
Banks that's right man Tom Banks and Tom
Banks he's quick I know when he's just
written and he goes to head like a head
start on Rex as well and you know Rhys
just turning
up to him yeah what about you Gia who's
uh who's the worst player you'd like to
see chasing you down
a lot of the suburbing players will be
able to catch me
they'll be excited
what about someone you'd be embarrassed
to sort of have catch you oh
uh probably like a boy Andrew mcelier
[Music]
if he caught me man I'd be like damn
[Laughter]
okay next one
um
George what's the hardest part about
preseason oh this one's gone
specifically to you though
um
yeah I guess uh
um it's definitely the grind day like um
you'll be under the pump not only
physically but mentally
um there'll be days where you wake up in
the preseason you like fire out we've
got to go do this and we gotta go I
don't know climb the sand dunes or go to
Bronco or we've got to go do wrestle and
run and
um just those things that tick in your
mind and it's like if you're kind of
gone with that mindset it's going to
make it worse for you so
um what I've found I guess is like yeah
you really have to just just almost fake
it like oh yeah I want to be here I
wanna it actually helps I find that it
helps and I always try and think like
Ethan black out of there so yeah
he attacks it from the friend he goes He
Walks towards to the challenge
so yeah that's that's a good mindset to
have you know like you think like Ethan
whatever you know Ethan would do he
would walk forward to any Challenge and
he'll eat it up no matter how hard it is
um but yeah pre-season is hard and
um I guess it's supposed to be hard
because it's supposed to challenge the
players and get the players really
mentally physically
um for the season I mean you do the hard
drive ads then so that when the season
comes you do you will get kind of get
the rewards so
um but yeah I like that I like that
mindset I might use that what would
Ethan
consistently ask myself what would Ethan
do in this situation
you're probably going to end up in a
good spot he loves it he loves it okay
this one's specifically for you seven
where did Cebu Learners dance moves
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
music playing or anything man you just
go crazy and you just start dancing and
you make up all these dance moves that
end up like you know it makes sense
that all just links together and you're
like and when you look back you're like
wow that actually looks like yeah
like yeah I always love you know
bringing the energy and yeah you know if
that includes dancing
um yeah I mean just feel it just feel it
yeah just yeah it's good to put smiles
on on the boys yeah even if it's a laugh
or it's yeah
yeah well no one does an after-game
celebration
Ugo like your energy and what you bring
to post games chance is pretty
impressive yeah yeah so I guess uh has
did it a bit in high school which is
good so you kind of just use that kind
of energy and yeah
um yeah it's always good to bring the
energies in bring the energy in and lift
the boys up after the game even though
some of the boys might not want to you
know single China after the game it's
always good to
boost their levels and yeah if they see
you going hard they're going to go
harder and if you see them if you if
they see you amping them up they're
gonna go yeah go harder so impossible
not to be in that bad one of your
performances they're very very
impressive okay favorite Crusader game
you've played in
oh
I think my one was you want to go first
or the the final last year 20 yeah 2020.
2022 yeah against the blues at Eden Park
man that was special man like
around you know in front of a sold out
Eden Park and
um up against a team that was undefeated
the whole season yeah yeah
um for us to go up there to the garden
and um win it like that
um boy as you're definitely definitely a
game that uh one of my favorite favorite
Crusader games yeah
yeah yeah I'd probably they're finally
last year was right up there man oh when
you scored your Triumph Pablo's cake
that must have been a moment
honestly that yeah that game there
because I remember that game dealer just
before they came I was just so nervous
like yeah I don't know what year I was
because I was dreaming with Rich and
um in Rich actually this one I was
because usually um yeah we've roomed
together a lot and then because this one
time I was or he turned around because
he likes to you know close his eyes for
a little bit like he's a little nap in
um and I do too as well so I was like
then he was having a nap and then
[Laughter]
[Music]
I didn't even know what was happening to
me and he was like laughing he was like
man this guy's yeah he's nervous yeah
and and yeah and obviously because they
um you know they came down to
Christchurch yeah they beat us here and
they've had a you know really good run
there you know
hey they hadn't lost the game so yeah
just lots of appreciables because man I
was cool to get that one at the end okay
next one who's the Carver King
oh there's only one I don't know
he's got the names as well this is cover
Soldier they call him cover Soldier
but he's just a soldier
[Music]
now we are all the boys just love me
yeah yeah down there and just it's
definitely the Fijian boys like you do
anyway it go it's always the feeding
boys lives here and
yeah we love it we love it how often
would you have it uh once a week yeah
once a week yeah after after a game
um yeah and some some teams do it
midweek um before day off and it helps
him relax and it gets unwind but yeah us
boys we just do it once a week after the
game and
go to connect and put the boys to sleep
every Fijian I feel like loves Kevin Hey
like any Fijian you play off around the
world they are heavily like how do you
get into it like what age do you start
drinking cover
uh I'm not just growing up you always
see your parents doing yeah um and uh
you see it's traditional as well and you
see it done in traditional ways and in
terms of you know to respect elders and
things like that so
um we kind of grow up grew up seeing it
so it's normal for us this is fijians as
Tongans as Islanders
um so yeah we probably get into it
around high school we help out you know
your 16 17 years old how about around
the tandoah um you know you told uh by
your mum sit here you have to sit here
and do it and then you end up just end
up drinking it so but by the time you
leave High School you're doing cover and
it's uh yeah not abusing it but yeah
yeah yeah yeah you're doing it uh yeah
we see it because you can't have too
much hey I remember having a big night
with ticket over in London Irish uh I
went there just expecting to you know
just have a few covers and ended up I
couldn't drive home I couldn't even
really stand oh yeah wow this stuff's
really yeah yeah and I know you can
drive on it but I was like man I I can't
yeah I can't drive I can't even walk to
this door yeah so I had to get an Uber
home but I was like man this Carver is
he must have some strong stuff but you
guys obviously know some of the some of
the good stuff as well yeah yeah nuts uh
can have a yeah bad effect of you on you
especially if you're you don't drink it
often as well and um yeah it is yeah
yeah just yeah if you do drink cover and
it's your first second third time just
drink responsibly yeah take it easy yes
or else you'll be locked there and
um yeah
oh good stuff okay next one asked George
how hard it was to stop playing sevens
and finally training to prop and go to
the gym it's from Scott waldram so he
obviously knows your seventh story
pretty well
uh was it so what did he ask in us he
just asked how hard was it to stop
yeah I remember Scott EOS like I don't
play seven Genie though you know it yeah
I love it I love his Heavens Amanda
um yeah it was uh yeah I guess yeah it
was it was wasn't too it sounds like it
did you good really yeah
exactly that and um yeah I found out
yeah it helped my past a lot especially
left and right kind of thing and not
just having one past kind of thing so
um but yeah that's probably why it took
me ages to put on a bit of good weight
because yeah I love sevens too much
during that summer you play a bit and
then you don't put on weight and yeah so
Scotty was always told me to you know go
to the gym and build a good strong back
foot scrubbing so he's always in my ear
but no he's a good man Scotty wardrobe
yeah he is okay next one how close was
George to playing for Fiji
[Music]
I was actually very close for the um 20
19 World Cup Yeah well yeah yeah sir
okay
um even the the coaches came came to
Christchurch and met up with myself and
Monday and civil and saying you know
there's
um they're real keen on having you as
well you're having us you know on board
for for the 2019 World Cup for Fiji
represent Fiji and things like that and
um you know you you representing your
country where you're from your heritage
and things like that so really kind of
like yeah I was yeah I was really like
wearing it up in back then I you know I
was like oh I had to get a lot of advice
from my parents from halitipolios yeah
use him as quite a good advice um
advisor I guess and uh you know they
always tell me you know you're just
scratching the surface man just give it
a couple more years you know you can
always go back to Fiji if if you don't
make it here so
um I listen to the advice and and I held
it down here unfortunately turn it down
and I guess it worked out for itself so
but I was very close I was I was very
close to to playing for Fiji that that
year and
um yeah it would have been a different
story if I did yeah yeah right massively
yeah yeah that's crazy so did you think
you were going to be in all black is
that where is that sort of what you had
to weigh up am I going to be in Auburn
yeah yeah I didn't think I was going to
be in all black at the time but I was
like oh this could be a chance there
where you know if I do keep pushing and
trekking on well I could make it so I
was like yeah I'll I'll sacrifice you
know playing for Fiji to to do a few
more years here and see what happens and
then yeah we could always play it off
after that so yeah and there were you
the same Civil War yeah yeah no the same
I remember when um because in 2019 our
first year we were living together in
um you know they like they'll message me
you know asking for George or like or
George's number or they'll ask George
for my number and yeah they like caught
up with us
um yeah sat down with meat as well and
the same thing happened you know they
told me oh you know would you want to
play it at this year's World Cup in uh
you know straight away I was I was I was
so close to going because I was like man
like I said earlier
um yeah but but and then because that
was kind of like just over halfway of
the super angry season
and then like I started playing
consistently and you know my old man
actually you know because I told him I
was like oh what do you think that'll be
cool if I play for Fiji you know like
it's always been a dream of mine to play
for Fiji and you know he said oh man are
you playing some good rugby at the
moment maybe just
like this white like this weight and
like you know like George you know
because I'm I can always go back and
play for veggies so yeah just waited and
yeah and then ended up praying for me
that's crazy so you guys you can play
for Fiji after is it how many what's the
standout now too I think it was three
three years so three years from not
being selected from yeah all blacks you
can play for Fiji yeah all right so this
ship will count as one you know yeah
who knows all right crazy
oh cool good stuff okay next one
um what was the hardest thing to
overcome to become an all black
[Music]
hmm tough one
oh I guess
um yeah I guess for me
um probably just the doubt the doubt
that I had in my mind um
getting up to my selection like thinking
that you know I'm not made for the
environment or I'm not supposed to be
there you know like
um and I think you know growing up I
always thought you know never it's never
possible so that was kind of like
um my mindset but yeah
um yeah now now looking back you're
going to have to change that and
understand that you know oh I guess yeah
try your best to remove that doubt and
say that you are you you know you you're
supposed to be there or you know my
family would always tell me that you
you're meant to be there you're there
for a reason and
um yeah I guess that was uh yeah that
kind of answered the question for me but
yeah yeah
things
him and well
um yeah for for me it would be like
um
you know like because I'm a Believer in
in a you can achieve anything if you put
your mind into it
in another pre as simple as I can put it
enough you know you're growing up as a
little kid you want to play for whatever
or like do whatever you know if you put
your mind into it and obviously
everything follows after that and he
and that's you wouldn't know you know
until you actually put everything into
it and you yeah a couple years later you
know you'll be looking back and they'll
probably be the best decision you've
ever made yeah you know like for us you
know we you know played for the All
Blacks in
you know it's I guess at one stage we
sort of had to get out of our comfort
zone and you know put our mind into you
know like training eating well and just
those little sacrifices
knowing that we want to be you know
a notebook one day I love us it sort of
goes into this last question which I do
ask everyone but it's going to be nice
to have two actually but the best piece
of advice you have for a woodland
listener so we've almost given our we
teaser there that you might have another
one for us who's got us
yeah trigger you're on you've got you're
full of advice man you've given plenty
what a journey too man
yeah I guess uh
um
oh man it's a
I've given a bit there
throughout this potty but uh
Matt you have
maybe I can
yeah just go back to what my old man
always told me like I said before if you
um if you do get an opportunity
um if you know not only with rugby but
if it's with your
um
you're you're schooling or your first 15
or work or anything and you just um
you know you get the opportunity to
and it's your time to shine you know you
take with both hands you do your best
that you absolutely can and make sure
that you've if no stone unturned because
you just never know who's who's watching
or who's looking up at you and
um if he sees it oh man you're working
thick and things like that and that
could be you know the Monumental change
to to and lead on to something greater
for for your career sir Chase Ryan
watching yeah yeah yeah Club feel yeah
and so yeah that's yeah it's I guess a
bit of advice that I can give some some
young bloke or young person watching or
listening to this party yeah I love it
can you beat that seven
oh wow
um I'm married I probably gave away my
best
maybe if you'd told us what the last
question was I could have like she's not
giving away too much
when I was saying that one I felt so
good you were in the flow hey I even
noticed it in your eye you're like wow
he's in a steak yeah
um yeah you know
one piece of advice for me would be you
know like like probably similar to what
I said before and I was like you can you
can be whatever you put yourself you
know like you whatever you want to be
like you know it's like you just put
your mind into it and we'll see I think
that it won't come easy and
um and I'd probably take that back to to
all of both me and Jill's rugby Journey
you know you put our Journeys together
you know that's kind of the same but
different you know like
um look at George this morning and he
took the long took the long Scenic Road
and I was Scenic um yeah and that's life
um you know but he didn't even give up
or anything yeah but and then every year
you just keep resetting your your goals
in their dreams and you know you you can
take them off every day and it's going
to be a day closer right it was even
better the second time around same
advice but even better oh wait you are
good you this could be a career field
you too advisors advice givers that's
what the knee's doing to us
sorry to jump back in here
um for anything that you just mentioned
because uh with our knees because we're
in the future room where I remembered um
generally telling me the other day man
like you talking like
so like mature and I'm like hang on but
yeah because all the because like I
don't know if you even realized when
when Jill was explaining about his knee
yeah some of the words he used in there
I'm I'm guessing you won't even know
I wanted to like like
yeah things like that like we like we
could tell you like yeah let me I could
tell you which part that is they're
sisters yeah yeah but now we yeah it's
really cool learning new things as well
big words as well yeah mate you've both
grown up so much yeah knee surgery it's
done wonders for you both but it's been
awesome having you on the podcast really
appreciate you too both coming on your
true Legends of New Zealand Rugby and I
know a lot of people in Fiji admire both
of you so much over there as well but um
awesome to sit down and catch up go
through the Journey and um love what
you're doing with the um we need Docker
as well so look forward to seeing the
release of those and um yeah the return
back onto the field but appreciate you
coming on Lads thank you thanks Jimmy
for for allowing us to uh to share share
our stories on your potty and uh man
we've enjoyed it and it's been awesome
chewing the fat with you and uh yeah
being on an awesome podcaster uh cheers
absolutely
thank you thanks
[Music]